[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Michal Borkowski,
and I'm the CEO
at Brainly, which is the biggest
global social learning network.
I strongly believe it's about
users, not about marketing.
So when we focus on users, when
we deliver the best quality
answers to them, then
we see the traction.
So it's all about execution.
Marketing, of course, helps.
But it is like a
follow-up to what we do.
It's not like the core of
our activities right now.
I find the most
interesting is that we
are putting the student
in the first place
in the whole educational system.
So we are creating the product
that users want to use,
that they love to use.
And that's why we believe
the disruption in education
will happen.
And then I strongly believe
that teachers and parents
will follow that direction.
So in our opinion, the
disruption in education
should start with
students, not with
the educational assistants,
teachers, or parents.